you know those people who say you
shouldn't buy appliances as gifts those
people are crazy I mean have you seen
that Samsung fringe with the giant
touchscreen on the front or the waffle
maker that's also an omelet maker the
point is buying home goods as gifts is
only a bad idea if the things that you
buy are boring and bad here's a few that
are neither starting with the Google
home which is easily the most crowd
pleasing gift you can buy this little
smart speaker looks like a vase or an
air freshener but it's actually a way to
quickly ask for the weather play music
set timers or play one of Google's
ridiculous games it's fun and useful and
anyone who can remember to say hey
Google will love them by the time you
get to the end of the holiday season
you're gonna need a drink that's just a
given
with the hoxsey home tap you can get
good smooth draught beer right in your
own kitchen hopsie curates the best
local beer and all you have to do is
slot it into the mini kegerator and pour
right now it's only available in the Bay
Area but look out for it elsewhere soon
speaking of much-needed escapes when
family time becomes a little bit too
much you can literally leave the world
with a PlayStation VR heads it's just
the easiest and most user-friendly of
all the virtual reality systems out
there they'll be able to play games
watch movies and generally avoid this
world in favor of a much better one
that's about the best gift you can give
anyone if you want to scale things back
a little bit you can buy the Xiaomi me
box one of the best new set-top boxes
out there since it runs Android TV it
has access to almost any streaming
service you can think of and it
integrates really nicely with Google
cast so anyone with a smartphone is
holding the remote it does HDR and 4k
and everything else right from that one
tiny box plus it's cheap so see not all
things for your home happen to be
appliances but here's one appliance that
is awesome the Dyson 360 iRobot vacuum
it looks like a little monster roaming
around cleaning your floor's doesn't it
that's basically what it is just turn it
on and let it go you make the mess it
handles the clean
anyone's home could stand to be a little
smarter a little more efficient and a
little more convenient the best home
gifts are all that and crazy fun to
enjoy that crazy phrase grandma